DUPLICATE THE KIND OF RUN THE
OILERS MANA HAS NOT
HANDLED THE PUCK CLEANLY.
AND THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN TIPPED
HOME BY THE NEWESTESN'T TAKE MU.
>> Jack: RUSSELL RINGS ONE OFF
THE POST IN GAME NUMBER 900,
SCORED 30
TWICE, 29 TO
DEFLECT THAT ONE UPSTAIRS FOR
PLAYED A REAL SOLID GAME FIRST
GAME INTO THE LINE-UP, INJURED,
MISSED TIME.
GOAL IN A WHILE.
>> Jack:
CONSECUTIVE 30-GOAL CAMPAIGN,
CORNER AND I DON'T KNOW IF THE
DEFENCEMAN PUT IT IN AFTER THE
SHOT PULJUJARVI, DISLODGES FOR
MCDAVID, GETS IT BACK FROM
THROUGH ALL THE TRAFFIC.
THAT WAS ANOTHER KEEP THAT OUT R
SIDE.
QUICK SHOT, BACKHANDER.KINNER C,
AND ANDERSON POUNCED ON IT TO
PUT MONTREAL B WINS THAT BATTLE,
GETS IT BACK TO CHIAROT,
CONSECUTIVE GAME AGAINST
MONTREAL NUGENT-HO THERE, LOOKS
UP, FINDS NUGENT-HOPKINS
BACKDOOR AND THAT SHOT,
SCORE!
ZACH HYMAN WITH
FRONT.
I DON'T THINK MONTEMBEAULT
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO GET
THERE AS QUICK AS IT FINDING TOE
CANADIENS WAIST TO GET
SET UP.
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT ONE-TIMERME !
HE'S GOT TWO TONIGHT, AND THE TY
FOEGELE, MONTEMBEAULT
LACROSSE GOAL BY TREVOR
PHILADELPHIA.
HERE'S HYMAN TO DRAISAITL,
BEAUTIFUL SEASON, DYLAN
HOLLOWAY, THE EDMONTON, SEVEN!
STARTED TO TURN SOUTH FOR THE
CANADIENS.
THEY COULDN'T FINISH